Excusez-moi vous savez que vous qu'on fête les 4 ans du mariage pour tous ? Du mariage homosexuel ?
Est-ce que vous, vous êtes, c'est un petit sondage,
Est-ce que vous êtes pour ou contre ?
Normalement, ce n'est pas bien.
Donc pour vous ce n'est pas bien ?
Non, ce n'est pas du tout bien.
Est-ce que vous êtes pour ou contre le mariage gay ?
Tout ça il faut assassiner, tout ça.
Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec les gens qui pense nécessairement qu'un enfant a besoin d'un papa et d'une maman ?
Oui, c'est nécessaire.
Les enfants c'est comme tout c'est un papa et une maman c'est tout.
Quelle est votre réaction si vous voyez deux hommes s'embrasser ?
Ça m'énerve tout simplement.
Ça me fait pas grand chose ça me dégoute c'est tout.
Salut bébé, ça va ?
Y a les flics qui sont en train de prendre ta voiture la bas.
Tu devrais y aller.
Oh putain non !
Salut Bébé !
Non mais je suis en pleine interview.
Excuse moi de te déranger mais y à ta voiture qui est en train de se faire enlever !
Tu restes là ?
Tu devrais y aller !
De quoi il parlait ?
Il parlait de cul.
Comment ?
De cul.
C'est quoi comme question qu'il vous à posé ?
Oh sur les pédés hein.
Comment ?
Appelé pédés quoi, comme on dit !
Les mecs comme ça faut les assassiner c'est tout.
Qui ça les pédés ?
Ben oui !
Faut les ?
Faut les tuer !
Faut faire le ménage !
Bon vous avez remarqué que j'en étais un quoi ?
Non !
Ah ben je suis vraiment homosexuel !
Pardon Monsieur !
Je suis désolé !
Re-tourne là !
Encore un autre parce que j'aime trop !
Allez j'y vais.
Quelqu'un m'a dit : ce sont les gènes qui sont malades.
C'est comme tout y en à qui on le vice de si ou le vice de ça !
Oui est-ce qu'il s'agit d'un vice ?
Vous les homosexuels vous les respectez ?
Bien sûr.
Faut les tuer !
Tuer !
Les Pédés ! Faut assassiner tout ça !
Du moment qu'ils sont polis, et qu'ils m'agressent pas, pourquoi je serais contre.
Faut les tuer !
Tuer !
Par exemple moi ça fait trois ans que je suis avec mon ami Jérôme.
On a envie d'adopter qu'est-ce ce que vous penser ?
C'est tout de suite 2000% de contre !
Bah pour moi c'est pas juste.
Fallait que je te coupe on viens de recevoir le mail !
C'est ok pour l'adoption du petit Jibril !
On va être, regarde !
Regardez !
On va avoir un enfant !
Vous pouvez nous dire félicitation ?
Je ne dirais rien du tout.
Merci monsieur aurevoir, bonne journée à vous.
Merci mon Dieu !